shock joke Howard Stern is the voice of
a Decepticon Jonah Hill is a comedic
relief and Revenge of the Fallen the
Transformers franchise could have looked
a whole lot different for all his
success it's surprising that Dwayne The
Rock Johnson doesn't have a long-running
signature franchise role of his own the
man who Forbes once called franchise
Viagra has used his star power to
reinvigorate other film sagas joining
sequels to Journey to the Center of the
Earth G.I Joe the Fast and the Furious
and even an episode of Star Trek Voyager
early in his career when the show needed
a rating bump you're no bigger than a
tarkanian field mouse paints insulted me
by putting you in the pit to face me and
in 2013 Johnson almost joined the
Transformer series when it needed a
boost at the time producers knew that
Shia LaBeouf wasn't coming back for the
fourth installments and so the film
needed a new lead before Michael Bay
settled on Mark Wahlberg however he had
a different man in mind given Johnson's
mix of beefy Brawn Ernest charm and
loads of Charisma it's no surprise he
was Bay's First Choice the star said on
Twitter in April of 2013 Michael Bay
offered me Transformers but I was
unavailable due to Hercules then
Wahlberg was offered the role when
Johnson missed out Wahlberg was rewarded
with a pair of films including
Transformers the last night
originally both movies underperformed
forcing the studio to Pivot to a prequel
leaving us to wonder if Johnson could
have saved the Transformers franchise
had he accepted the role Johnson is
still technically an official part of
the franchise he voiced an autobot named
cliff jumper in an episode of
Transformers Prime in 2010. you want the
whole arms
you got him
before Dwayne Johnson and Mark Wahlberg
were considered to lead the fourth
Transformers film the series was less
focused than brawny muscle-bound Heroes
instead it focused on more ordinary
Everyman like Shia LaBeouf so it
actually sort of makes sense that
producer Steven Spielberg came very
close to Casting a young Jonah Hill in
Transformers Revenge of the Fallen here
was hot off super bad at the time and a
major rising star known for goofball
comedies and still years away for more
serious dramas Like the Wolf of Wall
Street appearing in Transformers could
have altered the trajectory of his
career had he not turned it down enter
Seth Rogen writer actor and close friend
to Hill who evidently was responsible
for convincing Hill to pass up a role in
the first Transformer sequel in an
interview with the New York Times in
2021 Rogan recounted the conversation
where he said to Hill you want to make a
movie about fighting robots make your
own movie about fighting robots you can
do that that's on the table now with
Halo hot name at the time Rogan stressed
that he didn't have to take the first
big franchise movie that came along and
shouldn't be tempted just because a
legendary filmmaker Came Calling as
Rogan went on to say I can see if Steven
Spielberg's calling you asking you to do
something oh that's hard to turn down
osmo either roll Hill was being
considered for went to ragda Ramon
Rodriguez and Hill chose instead to have
a cameo in Ben Stiller's night of the
museum sequel thankfully passing on the
Transformers franchise probably didn't
give Hill much to regret since he went
on to star in plenty of hits even
getting a pair of Oscar nominations
along the way
many actors over the years have passed
up opportunities for roles in iconic
franchises and come to regret it however
sometimes an actor has no regrets at all
and turns down a part out of principle
and that's exactly what happened in the
case of Aziz Ansari star of master of
none and Parks and Recreation who passed
on an offer to play a small but racially
objectionable role in the very first
Transformers film in 2007. okay we'll
talk soon
there was no one on the other end of
that phone call and sorry revealed to
vulture in 2015 it was a role for like a
call center guy who has an accent and I
was like no I'm not doing it eventually
the role wound up being played by
ansari's friend and future master of
none co-star Ravi Patel though he
harbored no ill will and sorry still
isn't happy with Hollywood's racial
stereotyping and token diversity that's
a real thing that happens when they cast
these shows they're like we already have
our minority guy or a minority girl
there would never be two Indian people
in one show when it comes to radio shock
jokes the Undisputed King is Howard
Stern known for his raunchy radio Antics
and wild raucous gas he went from a
nationally syndicated Morning Show to an
anchor of satellite radio along the way
he wrote A Memoir that he turned into a
big screen movie when he started himself
in the 1997 biopic private parts however
he also came close to adding the role of
a transformer to his lengthy resume
while he's famous for his outsized
attitude and personality Stern is also
note suitable for his distinctive voice
so when Michael Bay was looking for
actors to lend their vocal talents to
the roles of the Transformers themselves
stern was a natural fit especially for
the role of frenzy vulture report system
was offered the role of the slippery
skittish Decepticon Spy Who disguises
himself as a radio and it seems no
coincidence that Stern a famed radio
shock chuck would be the pick to play
the part after turning down the role
Stern talked about why you passed it up
as reported by Dark Horizons my agent
gets a hold of me it's almost like he
shakes me up and smacks me he goes you
don't want to be in the movie as an
effing voice on the radio and I said you
know you're right after Howard sternfast
Michael Bay offered a role to Leicester
green an Entertainer and frequent guest
of the Howard Stern Show if you don't
recognize the name that's because he
usually goes by the name Beetlejuice and
he uses a moniker across numerous spots
on Stern's radio show as well as in
movies like Bubble Boy and scary movie
2. Jews in the house this is your
friends on drugs
on an episode of certain show the actors
manager Bobby Rooney talked about how
green had been approached for a role in
Transformers Revenge of the Fallen years
before leading to them going to meet
with Bae as Rooney described it Bay
arrived with a laptop which he used to
pitch bee to a juice on the character
and he has a character of Beetlejuice
with uh of one you know one of the uh
robots for beetlejuice's voice
unfortunately the famously Mercurial
comedian was in one of his moods
according to Rooney and it was a
non-starter as Rooney recalled the bay
was eventually put off by Green's
flippant attitude and realized it
probably wouldn't be fun working with
him anyway Corey Burton is a veteran
voice artist who has contributed to a
number of Transformer cartoons over the
years with his most notable role being
the voice of the villainous Shockwave in
the original animated series from 1984.
it was also nearly recruited for the
live-action Transformers films according
to Burton himself on his website he was
approached for several possible roles in
the big screen adaptations he wrote I
was given the opportunity to audition
for jazz a totally incomprehensible
request for me to even attempt and brawl
but it was just a one-line cameo bit
that didn't seem worth jumping through
all the audition Hoops Beyond turning
down an offer to appear in the first
Transformers film it doesn't sound like
Berta never really wanted to be involved
with the live-action series and was
happy to say in the animated corner of
The Saga
actor and rapper Ashley Walters may not
have the high profile of Dwayne Johnson
or Howard Stern but he's a highly
respected star with plenty of big
projects under his belt he's appeared on
television in hits like hustle and
starred in the lead role in the British
crime drama top boy in the mid-2000s he
was also offered a starring role in the
first Transformers film they offered me
Tyrese's room and the Transformers
franchise unfortunately what would have
been a major role for the up-and-comer
just wasn't on the cards since it
already signed a contract to act in an
independent drama called Life and lyrics
still waltzes didn't seem too regretful
and has plenty of perspective obviously
that could have been a life changing
thing but at the same time if I did that
I wouldn't have done top boys before
Transformers young actor Shia LaBeouf
had practically made a career out of
playing Sidekicks with roles next to the
likes of Keanu Reeves and Will Smith in
movies like Constantine and iRobot in
2007 it finally played the action hero
himself starring as bumbling teenager
Sam whitwicky in Transformers a film
that turned him into a superstar 50
years from now when you're looking back
at your life don't you want to be able
to see you at the guts to get in the car
it reprized a role in a pair of sequels
and each was more successful than the
last however when the time came for a
fourth installment Shire turned it down
the actor sold MTV not longer after the
release of Transformers Dark of the Moon
in 2011. I just don't think right now
the us anywhere to take Sam I was 17
when I met Michael and I'm source of
Michael Bay race and it's not that I
don't enjoy working with Michael I love
working with Michael I would do any
movie Michael wants to do yes the one
movie he wouldn't do with Bae was a
franchise's next film Transformers age
of Extinction forcing Bay to hire Mark
Wahlberg to succeed the buff as a series
lead